those politicians supported by the NRA
that allow the continued slaughter of
our children in our future
I say get your resumes ready the
students of Stoneman Douglas High School
in parkland Florida have reenergized the
National Movement to restrict gun
ownership following the tragic mass
shooting that claimed 17 lives the
culmination of this movement was the
massive March for our lives rally in
Washington DC I'm here to help stop gun
violence
I just think enough is enough and I
don't want to see any more lives being
lost I want less children to die the
students from Stoneman Douglas have
earned praise for their leadership in
demanding that Congress take decisive
action but there's another consequence
of this movement which is that the
Parkland mass shooting seems to be
stoking irrational fear about gun
violence in schools I'm here cuz I want
to feel safe in my school you'd come
away from the March for our lives
thinking that there's a mass shooting
epidemic in American school I do think
it's more dangerous in schools there's
more school shootings now we're all in
danger but what happened at Stoneman
Douglas was an extremely rare occurrence
American schools are profoundly safe and
most likely getting safer according to
researchers at Northeastern University
shooting incidents involving students
have actually decreased in recent years
and in the 1990s the overall crime rate
was much higher than it is today the
rate of homicides from firearms in the
US has plummeted in fact students are
orders of magnitude more likely to die
in a car crash on their way to school
than they are to be gunned down in their
classrooms yet the protesters were
demanding more security in schools a lot
more so do you think there should be
more police officers in schools
trained officers or security guards
should be the ones protecting students
even if it means making armed guards a
fixture of the lives of children
I support sensible gun policy it's
simple no guns less violence we should
stop having guns anywhere at all like I
feel like guns should be outlawed I just
would like to see guns illegal
this latest hysteria over mass shootings
and guns is leading to claims that we
must relinquish our rights in the name
of safety which is a familiar story from
the drug war to the war on terror
teenagers have every right to fight for
a cause they believe in and the students
from Stoneman Douglas are justifiably
enraged about an event that claimed the
lives of so many friends and classmates
but feelings shouldn't trump facts and
we should never craft policies from a
place of fear in the wake of tragedy
there should be more regulations or
there should just be more laws that just
needs to be something up happening
thoughts and prayers don't do much
anymore it's just I'm just kidding it's
just tired of it
you